All these pro-independence groups,
think about it.
Just percat.
left,
not so small group,
eh.
Careful,
Republican Left,
even Bildu,
are very anti-Spanish.
They hate everything Spanish and yet,
to collect the public salary
are the most patriotic.
The gentlemen of John spercat,
4 deputies receive almost €400,000 per year,
paid by taxpayers from Badajoz,
Seville,
of Huelva,
Malaga and Merida.
The gentlemen of Esquerraa,
you remember,
almost one million euros a month,
do not protest a little bit
and a little bit.
They really like Spanish money.
Spain is not stealth,
eh,
no,
sir.
But Bildu also
collect assets from the Spanish.
Mr. Oscar Matute,
which is not there today,
lest he earn his salary with his presence,
earns €117,000 per year
of the Spanish state that they so deplore